The key to long-term travel is finding jobs that will take you to new places,...
...help you save cash and let you travel in your free time.
Teaching English is a great way to immerse yourself in foreign culture,...
...learn a new language and travel on the weekends.
In countries like the UAE or Korea, the pay is high...
...and they'll oftentimes cover accommodation and flights,...
...which is a great option if you have student loans.
These days, certain jobs can be done from anywhere,...
...whether it's programming to graphic design or freelance writing and photography.
The key is "geoarbitrage," earning money in a strong currency and spending it...
...where life's a little bit cheaper.
School is free in many European countries.
In Scandinavia, they even pay you to go to school.
There are also scholarships that will fund you to do research abroad.
Most major corporations have offices overseas,...
...oftentimes in really cool countries with a lower cost of living.
So, instead of quitting your job, you could just outsource yourself.
Apply for a transfer for six months to a year...
...and that can be even better than getting a raise or the corner office.